Oh PewDiePie
He's running out of ideas
"Oh it's so obvious PewDiePie is running out of fresh ideas!"
Oh yeah?!
Well there is one--
I still got one card
One card left to play
The most desperate card
In ALL of YouTube!
*beautiful music :D*
I never thought I would sink this low.
I'm disgusted
What kind of clickbait
title could we put on this one?
*stutters*
just "Ask me Anything"
"Does PoodiPie do Drugs?"
That's the title of the video now everyone
That's the title...
...of the video
OH! You noticed uh we have some guests in the studio today
*Claps to non-existent cardboard cutouts*
Clap it up everyone
We have your mama!1!1!
Giant black-- *decides not to continue*
We have Cinnamoooon!.... Toast Ken everybody.
And... Let's not forget, our special guest,
Maaaaaaaaaaaaarkiplier.
*crickets chirping*
Accurate- accurate size *laughs*
*whispers* I'm talking about his penis
We also have ME here!
No, I'm not compensating for Ainsley. Shut the fuck up!
Where should we put this beau- look how beautiful he is.
Cardboard Felix- Please, Felix, don't put me in the ceiling
Shut up Felix! You're going in the fucking ceiling!
He ha he hleee ha hleee  :P
I don't have any questions just want you to delete a happy wheels video
What the hell man!?
What the HELL!
*scary noise*
*horribly sings*When you try your best...
I feel like we need some sad music for this, cause...
*Sad Music*  Which one should we go with uh.... Alright, uh, episode 53.It's been uh, it's been good buddy.... You're out.
You're out!
Alright, next question
Next question comes from Brad, one of my editors
Will you let my family go, I've worked hard enough
I'll leave this one, to the gaymode.. team
*Robot voice* Unfortunately, Brad's family has suffered Stockholm syndrome and wish to stay with Felix forever.
Well, well, well, Brad, it seems like your family
*voice, getting higher* has choose stay with me a little longer
Sorry :(
*sad music*Alright, episode 60, you're out
Out of all the people in the world, what made you choose me to be in your background?
Wait...
Ainsley Harriot?
*laughs*
Wait is this real!?
Is that the real Ainsley!!?
What?
But he was-
He was de-
Aaaaaahhhhh!
Ainsley, is a real... person?
Anyway, episode 41. It's been nice... it's been nice.
Next, quest-
Next question
Cardboard Felix- Kiss me
Felix!
I'm not- I'm not gonna spiderman kiss you
Ask Pewds
Smash or pass:JK Rowling
Um...Gonna have to let the gang take care of that one
What's that?
Sell to slavery!
Sell! That, bitch to slavery!
It's really offensive to say, to sell someone to slavery, Felix
You don't understand the history and the struggles
That JK Rowling went through
JK Rowling used to be very poor
And then she wrote some books
Then she became a whiny bitch on twitter
You don't understand her struggle
Alright, shit, I keep forgetting I have to delete a fucking video
Like it's not funny. Why did I come up with this idea?
*laughs*
There's not any value to the video
Which one, uh, which one do you think? I think it's time for like one of the earlier ones
Someone, somewhere, right now, is going like that Trump lady at the inauguration.
About me deleting these videos
Noooooooooooo!
Goodbye, episode 11
*sad music*
Can you re-enact the "my name jeff" scene from 22 jump street?
No
No, I'm not going to do that. What do look like? Some sort of whore?
*claps*
I've been practicing. I've been practicing a lot for this.
*awkward laugh*
My name, uh
*High pitch, RIP headphone users*Jeff!
I have to dele-
Delete another video
Why does no one love me?
*sad music*
Because you're wearing Hitler glasses
There, *stutters*
You're wearing not fascist glasses
Okay? Know you're- you know you're a bit young, but, uh...
But, you need to not do that
Cause that's why no one loves you
When will you watch the true epic love story that is HoshiPie
What is this, exactly?
*sexy music*
You guys are fucking weird
You guys are good at editing
And I appreciate you
Than- Thank you, very nice
Now I finally have some fapping material
I've been- been running out for awhile
Guess now we have to delete another fucking video
*inaudible muttering*
21!
Is that a... is that a meme?
Is that a meme right? That's a meme.
Do you think Phil Lester deserves more appreciation
Uh... No, I think he's a little overrated
I, uh, would like to say, uh, that I'm more of a Dan man.
If you know what I mean
Goodbye
Episode seven-
You guys want 2012 pewdiepie back?Yeah, well I want 2012 Youtube back! Okay?
So much better
Tell em Ainsley, oh....
*sad music*
Why is Emma Blackery...
So big?
Like what happened here?
I don't understand.
Emma, do you have anything to say, to uh...
This is the first time we collab on this channel
What, what would you like to say?
Carboard Emma- You're gay
I'm gay?
Wow!
*sigh* So sick of deleting these fucking things
Like why did I...
Why am I still here?
Like this one fucking had four million views
*burp*
Life's not fair!
When will you kill yourself?
Another happy wheels video
*laughs*
No, not episode three!
Not episode THREE!
Ask pewds, read this to die instantly
*dies*
*sad music*
Yes!
YEESSS!
My time to shine!
Finally!
I'm taking over this fucking gay ass channel man!
Are you the reincarnation of Adolf Hitler?
I can neither.. I can nein-ther
*laughs*
Confirm or de-nein
*claps*
*sad music*
Episode ten
Goodbye!
Do you miss simpler things in life after gaining huge popularity?
It's honestly not that different
If you follow me throughout the, throughout an entire day
I think you'll realize that I
I'm
I'm pretty much doing whatever you doing
I'm, I'm pretty much the same. You know?
I think you'd actually be pretty overwhelmed how boring my life actually is behind the scenes.
Uh...
I only snort a couple pounds of cocaine every day
Only a couple hookers
five or six
Every night, and, uh...
And that's another Happy Wheels video
Do you lovee make sex with marza or no or are you thinking to bring BABBBYYYY!
I imagine that's how they wanted it.
Well, that's another Happy Wheels video
That was.. thank you for that. Thank you, appreciate the great question
Uh, not thinking to bring any babies
No, I- I do not
*Pewdiepie editied singing chainsmokers music* I was doing just fine before I met you
*music* I drank to much and that's an issue
*music* But I'm okay
*music*What!
*music*
*music* Hey!
*music* You tell your friends it was nice to meet them, but I hope I never see them again
*music*
Pewdiepie speaking over music- That's cool!                                    *Music* I know it breaks your heart
*music* moved to a city in a broke down car
Pewdiepie over music- That's really fucking cool            *Music* And
*music* Four years, no calls
Pewdiepie speaking over music- That must have taken for fucking forever                                                                                                              *music*And now you looking pretty in a hotel bar
*music* I-I-I-I-I
Can you slow dance with Slippy?
*music*
I'm scared! I'm too scared, I can't!
And that's another Happy Wheels!
Alright, and final question
Can you do a backflip?
No
Now we're going to have a silent moment. For all the lost...
Happy wheels videos
*Sad Music*
Alright then, so leave a like if you enjoyed this video
If you did, ummmm....
Ken!
Is going to do something really funny
If you click- click it right now and see something really funny is going to happen
Any moment
Any moment!
At any moment!